أنا في حالة تأهب في هذا الوقت بعد
ظهر أمس، وكانت بقايا مركز الشرطة في هذه المنطقة
تحت
سيطرة حماس، وكان هناك قتال عنيف من قبل
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية في
الساعات الأولى من هذا الصباح، الساعة 4 أو 5 صباحًا
بالتوقيت المحلي هذا الصباح قبل استعادتها.
السيطرة على مركز الشرطة هناك، انظر
إلى الدمار، انظر إلى مقدار
القوة التي كانت مطلوبة لاستعادتها
من مسلحي حماس الذين
سيطروا على هذه البلدة، ما الذي أراه
وأسمعه الآن في البداية عند
الوضوح ولكن  أسمع طائرات بدون طيار في
الهواء وكان ذلك بمثابة انفجار، ربما
سمعت أننا نسمع الكثير من
الانفجارات هنا نسمع
طائرات مقاتلة في الهواء، هذه المدينة
مهجورة بالكامل تقريبًا، فقط عدد قليل من المدنيين الذين
نراهم  هنا نخرج
ونتحدث مع بعضنا البعض حول ما
حدث هنا على اليسار،
سأوجه جون لتشغيل الكاميرا على
هذه السيارة، كان هذا جزءًا من تبادل إطلاق النار
بالأمس، إنه موقف دموي للغاية
على الجانب الآخر من السيارة
لن نعرض لك ذلك ولكن فقط انظر
حولك هنا اه جون إذا تابعتني
على الأرض هنا انظر إلى كل
أغلفة القذائف المتناثرة
على الأرض هنا بيكي هذا
يعطيك مؤشرًا على شدة
القتال  أنه في جميع أنحاء
الأرض هنا بينما كنا نسير في مكان ما في
النصف ساعة الأخيرة، وقع
انفجار آخر هناك، هذه مجرد
خلفية عامة، كان الإيقاع على بعد أميال قليلة وعلى بعد بضعة
كيلومترات من غزة،
تبدو لنا تلك الانفجارات وكأنها قادمة من
داخل غزة  الطائرات المقاتلة مرة أخرى
بالإضافة إلى انفجار آخر هناك عندما
تقود سيارتك إلى حيث تمر بمركبة تلو الأخرى
المتضررة التي تم إطلاق النار عليها، حتى
أننا مررنا بالقرب من مركبة شرطة
بها ثلاث طلقات واضحة عبر
الزجاج الأمامي مباشرة إلى المكان الذي كان من المفترض أن
يجلس فيه السائق حماس  جاءوا إلى
هنا مرة أخرى، لا يمكنك التقليل من أهمية هذا الأمر،
فهم لم يفعلوا ذلك أبدًا قبل أن يأتوا
إلى الإحصائيات ويسيطروا عليها، ومن
الواضح أن حماس تقول إنهم ما زالوا
يقصفون هذه المدينة، لذا إذا انطلقت صفارات الإنذار،
فلدينا ثوانٍ للوصول إلى
المخابئ  هنا، لا تزال هذه
منطقة ساخنة للغاية ونشطة للغاية في هذه المنطقة،
الأمن مشدد للغاية، ترى الجنود
عند نقاط التفتيش وهم ينزعون
أسلحتهم عن أسلحتهم، ترى جنودًا يمرون
عبر الحقول بحثًا عن أماكن
ربما كانت هناك تقارير تفيد
بوجود مقاتلين من حماس حماس
تم القبض على مسلحين شمالًا من هنا وهم
يحاولون التسلل اليوم إلى عمق
إسرائيل، لذلك لا يزال الوضع غير متكافئ للغاية
ولكن بداية
التطهير عند النقطة الأولى لما تبقى من
مركز شرطة ستوت الذي بدأ للتو
الآن بيكي